so so hello everybody I would like to
present you present you Rachel Fulton
Brown she's a professor at the
University of Chicago and we met to
Facebook and to being interested in
Jordan Peterson and we realized we had a
lot of interesting things in common
including our interests in medieval
theology medieval symbolism art so many
things so we're going to we're going to
have will t have an interesting
discussion about all that but maybe
Rachel you can introduce yourself a bit
more in more detail oh thank you Jordan
Jordan Jonathan ah yes I have Gordon in
Milo in my mind so some of you may know
me as fencing bear at prayer because
Milo has been sharing some of my blog
posts about him over the last year I'm
also a great fan of Jordan Peterson
because I'm very interested in the way
in which he talks about mythology and
religion and psychology so I'm really
excited to have this conversation with
Jonathan because I'm very interested in
the way in which his art matches with
the kinds of storytelling that I see
Jordan doing and Milo actually
portraying and living so I'm happy to be
here thank you for having me so I've
been you know and most people will be
watching this although I've been friends
with Jordan for a chief for almost two
years now and I have been paying
attention to Tamiya innopolis ever since
the umass event with trigger lee puffin
all that I've been I've been following
and being very attentive to what she's
been because I saw in him a lot of the
symbolism of a marginal symbolism that
I'd been interested in for the last few
years and so maybe you could when you I
heard that you were friends with Milo I
was I was extremely surprised but maybe
you can just quickly tell us how you met
him how you're in contact with them how
exactly did a you know a history
professor at University of Chicago
become friends with him what so tell me
why were you surprised when you heard
that I was friends with him well just
because he I mean I don't like I how can
I say this I think that I see him I see
him as being maybe I'm wrong and I saw I
saw him as being maybe more unconscious
as what than what I thought
and so and so when I when I saw what you
were doing and the type of symbolism
that you're talking about and and your
understanding of kind of you know the
types of patterns that existed in the
medieval world view I was like huh you
know maybe yeah maybe he's more aware
than I think and so it got me really
curious about about how you met him and
kind of what type of discussions we've
had with him everything because I I'm
very fascinated I'm very fascinated by
what he kind of represents well that's
interesting you say that what you what
you were startled by is that he seems
whether you're wondering whether he's
conscious of what he's doing and why I
can see it well I say one of the things
that absolutely fascinates me about Milo
is how well he embodies that archetype
that Jordan recognized when he was
interviewed about Milo in February that
Milo is this trickster figure and you
know I think if Milo were actually I
think he's conscious of it and
unconscious of it at the same time and
it's like it's sort of amusing for me as
the medievalist to be watching him and
then seeing the symbolism that he's
playing out because I think if he were
doing it in a more sort of conscious way
it wouldn't be as quite as effective but
maybe I should you want me to tell that
my story about how I got in touch with
him yeah I mean just briefly there we
enjoy so um back in September I was well
I was finishing up the book that I'm
working on and that I hope you and I get
to talk about on the symbolism of the
Virgin Mary
so I guess my head was just absolutely
full of all of the kinds of symbolic
resonances that medieval Christians used
to use and the deans of our College sent
out a letter to our incoming freshman
saying that if they cut when they
country the University of Chicago they
should not expect to find safe spaces
and trigger warnings in their syllabi or
in their classes that come to the
university expecting rigorous debate and
challenging arguments over the last over
the previous winter I had been involved
in in a kind of online a smaller online
argument with some of my colleagues in
Medieval Studies over a post I had done
back in
in 2015 but I labeled three cheers for
white men purposely to get everybody's
attention to make an argument that their
their very positive elements of the
Western Christian European and therefore
also American tradition that we and our
culture would do better to actually
acknowledge rather than simply saying
all white men are potential rapists and
that they're the problem and my three my
three cheers were shoveled the idea of
chivalry the idea of marriage as
something that involves the consent of
both the man and the woman and the
political right for women to have the
vote and I reminded my readers at the
end of that that little post that if he
knows you want to argue with me remember
that one of the great freedoms that we
have in the West is the idea of the
freedom of speech right well so that
post from June 2015 sort of sat on the
internet being ignored for six months
until one of my colleagues in Medieval
Studies found it for books that she was
writing on digital whiteness and and you
know thereafter history is made she
found my post and a bunch of my
colleagues in Medieval Studies got very
excited about the fact that they found a
real white you know white supremacist
Burma they thought they thought they
found me right so they left on Twitter
and they left on Facebook and and in
that moment a friend of mine mentioned
to me that my post was getting some
attention and I sort of left into the
fray on the Facebook group in the happy
warrior guys that I've been trying to
trying to cultivate into hi everyone
here you have the problem of my post
let's talk about it and by the end of
that afternoon I managed to change the
conversation sufficiently that the only
person left really arguing with me with
the original poster who was that with me
and I realized in that moment that you
know this is what I've been waiting for
right I needed to make these arguments
for our culture so I did a long series
of posts on chivalry and on different
ideas of freedom in the United States
and
you know the sort of larger arguments
that I wanted to start making about the
value of Western civilization and the
problems that we're having in the
Academy so in September when our our
Dean sent out that letter I was already
kind of primed to be in that aspect of
the culture war I was a little bit aware
of Milo from the previous spring because
another colleague and I of mine had also
gotten caught up in the white
supremacist misogynist labeling at about
the same time the feminists found me and
he actually Alan Frandsen like my good
friend got shamed much more effectively
than I did they we can't say or there's
some conferences sessions that in his
honor that were canceled and a fest risk
that was pulled from publication and
because Alan himself is gay um he was we
were both sort of aware of what was
going on with Milo but we weren't really
sure like who is he and so I was mildly
aware of the uprising at DePaul when
Milo was prevented from speaking by the
black lives matter protesters but I was
I hadn't really properly paid attention
to it so September comes I'm you know
sort of in a good place with my book to
be paying attention to some of the other
things that have been happening letter
come out from the Dean and I say fine
I'm curious i'ma do list think it's a
it's a bad idea to condemn someone as a
heretic without a proper Inquisition um
so I went and watched a you know as many
of Milo's talks as I could and in like
three days
all the ones had been posted from the
previous spring and at the end of those
three days I wrote to him because I and
I labeled that post three cheers for
white men but that would work to get his
attention
dear mr. gianopolous I teach at the
University of Chicago I'm sure you've
heard about this letter that our Dean's
have just sent out I'm in this and I put
some links on from the chivalry posts
that I done I even admire you greatly as
does my dog
they mentioned the dog and I you know
thank you for doing what you're doing
well he wrote back immediately and after
that we we stayed in contact over email
with me sending him things to read
suggesting further things that I I
thought he might find useful to look at
and from I and watching all of his talks
so that I really knew everything that he
was saying and and you know it's been
the most wonderful experience for me
over the last year because it's been
wonderful having a friend who was as
fully engaged in the fight as I knew we
needed to be in order to really make the
cultural arguments that we have to
mm-hmm and so I thought so the here's
here's here's my big question for you
regarding that because I've been
thinking about I've been thinking about
him and kind of what what he is or what
he represents and everything so the
question is if he is a trickster how how
does that work like how how is he a
trickster on the conservative side like
how do you see that happening right now
it seems like usually let's say in a
mythological images the trickster is
there to to unbind let's say or to
loosen things that are too too strict
resident in his case it's very ambiguous
so I like to get your take I have my own
ideas about that but I like to get your
take on that well I think you're right
it's ambiguous which is the role of the
tricksters that he is standing on the
border between all of the different
sides and as he said quite well I think
in his little panel discussion on the
Bill Maher show but you know belt the
alt-right hates him just as much as the
out left does the T so point to coin a
phrase right that's the extreme right in
the extreme left both find him
problematic and you know the trickster
needs to be the one that stands on the
bat on the Border's and shows up the
sort of rigidity of both sides now that
it's interesting to me that of course
Milo initially was being invited to give
his campus talks primarily
I student groups he always did his talks
for free for the students who invited
him and the groups that were inviting
him to the campuses were typically the
College Republicans and the young
Americans for liberty so you know
politically they they were mr. what we
tend to think about as at least more
conservative than not although and and
of course because he had the good
fortune of doing this campus tour during
the election year meant that the country
was quite excitable on as we get in
election years and he he came out very
strongly for Donald Trump primarily said
because he thought Trump would be I
think he sees Trump as another kind of
of potential trickster character that he
he always liked Trump as someone who was
going to break down but the political
correctness that had been stifling
everyone's speech now what I think would
say I think you're saying he's ambiguous
it he is his his primary mode of
engaging with people is through humor
and jokes right and and he loves saying
that nobody can resist resist the truth
rapt and a good joke and his motto as it
were which he gets from GK Chesterton in
fact is recess at bellum laughter in war
right that if we're going to win the
culture war you win with joy not
grimness and I think what what the
Conservatives who of the kinds of
political conservatives that originally
invited him to CPAC and then got cold
feet when the videos came out in
February about his his adolescent sexual
life showed is you know they are as
scared of a joke as the leftist has been
typically proving itself to be and and
so what what Milo I've written a lot
about what I think Milo shows us in
terms of the importance of humor and and
the the way in which humor is sort of
scary my law so likes talking about how
the thing that Tyra I apologize for my
dog she's just going to do that the
thing that tire pirates hate most is the
fan
laughter because it's it's the place
where people are actually and I have
thought about this a lot it's like you
you need structure and order for society
to exist right societies can't exist
without some kind of order and you and I
both know that Jordan talks about this
regularly but you know you need the
structure of the walls and the and the
hierarchy and the the ordering
institutions in order for for anybody to
be able to live otherwise we're in chaos
right but structure itself could become
so rigid as to become itself tyrannical
and I think what Milo is doing with his
laughter and his his willingness to
stand there you know can imagine
standing there on the city walls and
pointing both inside and outside and
saying those of you who think you're
safe inside need to loosen up a bit and
and have some fun and be able to make
jokes at yourself and recognize Neos it
the more you try to be morally pure the
more visible you're going to become but
likewise those who mean are saying
they're standing on the outside of the
city and and saying we don't want any
structure and we don't want to need laws
need to be able to laugh at themselves
and what I have just you know Milo I did
a blog post just from this last weekend
I got to visit with him in person he's
just a joyous delightful person to be
around because he's filled with with um
laughter right and it's it's not it's
not just it's not vicious laughter at
other people it's laughter himself it's
laughter at the idea that you know it's
possible to have fun as well as as
recognized the importance of our
traditions mm-hmm and so I mean I think
the big question that that I've seen
people around me let's say asking is
what Kijiji obviously said he's Catholic
and sometimes sometimes it feels like
he's saying he's kicked he has all these
different identities and so depending on
the situation he can point to one
identity and then kind of like a like a
snake or he can slither out of it of a
difficult situation so he can say I'm
Jewish and then kind of you know get out
and then say I'm gay and then get out
but then also be like a white man and
then get out and then but then he also
has this one which is
like Catholic no sometimes you can you
can throw back with it I'm being cynical
when I say that but my question is what
to what what what extent do you think
that his Christianity with Sarah's
Catholicism is part of his identity or
or is not part of his identity is part
of what she's trying to do let's say I
think it's everything I think that the
one thing that if you if you watch him
and obviously I've watched him pretty
carefully if you watch him the one thing
that is absolutely utterly consistent
about his costume is his cross he always
wears it and and he has several across
the city wears the necklaces but in
every photograph that he's ever taken
except for when he's wearing a suit and
tie but I think the crosses are
underneath he's always wearing a cross
that's invariable um he used the thing
about being Jewish most strongly over
over the summer and into the autumn when
Steve ban and his former boss at
Breitbart was persistently being called
anti-semite and Milo was trying to help
Steve in that in that context saying
well look he hired me and you know if
you're going with Nazi levels of what
counts as Jewish I'm Jewish because his
mother is of Jewish descent um that he's
gay
and yet recognizes or feels that it's
complicated
is of course not something that the
strong left LGBTQ activists will admit
because Milo says well you know on the
one hand it seems that being gay is
something that I am and on the other it
does seem to be something that it's you
know now that we know how he grew up was
was as it were encouraged into by other
people so you know the he's saying and
that you know he thinks being gay is
itself a kind of liminal status whether
its nature or nurture whether it's for
in this way or something that you can
actually change and and he has said
quite poignant ly a number of times how
he he wishes that he weren't gay because
that being gay
and and he does actually mean he has as
he said in one of his interviews
recently had love in his life he he does
have very deep friendships with with
some of the men that he's been with but
that means he's not going to have
children and he is also very fond of
children and the idea of having his he
says little Milo's so I think I think in
his the ambiguity is is his his
acknowledgment of what it means to be
human and what it means in fact to be
truly Catholic that your cat I mean was
when he people push him on it in his Q&A
says what why are you Catholic how a
needy Catholic I said well what else
would I be on the center-right and and
it's very interesting how hard it is for
people to hear someone just simply say I
know I do things in my life that are
sinful and I you know I celebrate them
or I haven these riotous ways but I also
recognize that they've been damaging to
me in in in my personal life so I know
it he's I keep getting in trouble for
making you know comparisons to come to
Jesus but in in the sense of the sort of
one who is dangerous because he comes
into the middle of the culture and
challenges its authorities I think
there's there's very interesting
resonances but that he is he's willing
to take on the the insults that
everybody throws it and for actually
pointing out the ambiguity of our all of
our situations I think he's setting
himself up as a and it's an example of
saying well you think you're so pure on
the conservative side he's a number of
times said you know this for twenty
years ago I'd be arguing against the
conservative right and he's showing how
that the concert you know the
conservative left whatever it is that
the rigid left both sides is I see they
meet you know they've met at the back
and their granny agreeing with each
others at the back so each insisting on
their own purity and and I low is
showing you know I mean your that purity
is a fantasy
mmm-hmm and and also sinful because it's
it's making this claim that you can
somehow be purer than God yeah well
there is a there's such a large strain
of like puritanical Christianity and you
it's very strong so there's a vision of
Christianity which is you know the the I
mean just the fact that there was
prohibition in the United States kind of
shows you what type of vision of
Christianity is underlying the the
culture and so so I can understand how
that would definitely for him saying I
have this in my life that I'm struggling
with I know that it's a problem it's
there you know deal with it you know
it's like like I'm still believe and I'm
still Catholic I still believe in these
things I've got this thing I've got
these things around me and like ER so I
get I mean I can understand how that
would be extremely problematic for both
both sides because that the debate about
the debate about about about
homosexuality especially in the church
and then like do we reject them or do we
accept them and like that's not the
answered if that's not how it works you
know it's it's anyway so like you said
it's complicated and I think that that's
that's interesting yes III think I agree
with you that that seems to be what he's
doing at least so yeah so yeah so thanks
for thanks for that I mean it's helping
me because obviously I've been paying
attention to him and then since the fall
out and everything I would get like a
lot of people I kind of pulled away
mm-hmm then when I saw that you were
still writing about him and you were
still talking about him like okay maybe
I need to to pay attention again I
haven't read the I haven't read his book
but but I guess I still need to keep my
eyes open on what Sean Lydia's like he
might what he's possibly doing well I'm
happy to hear that it was my blog that
kept kept because I had so if you all
look back at the week in February when I
was writing about a movie it was quite a
week for me right because he had well I
had become infamous among my academic
colleagues because an article had come
out in the divinity school newsletter
citing on Thursday about the week that
was two weeks after the Berkeley riot
and the editor at sightings had asked me
to write a piece on what I thought was
my low significance for American
academic culture and I'd said well you
know he shows us the importance of think
about religion and that made them all
upset though from the Thursday through
that weekend my colleagues had spent
that time on a listserv that I was
actually party to which they should have
realized talking about all the terrible
things that I had said I did a blog post
on that and so I spent you know that we
can sort of ramping myself up to be you
know kind of public win my support from
Iowa and that Monday was when the video
dropped with the clips of his race his
his sexual upbringing and so then it was
I was suddenly there public but on my
low side and and there was absolutely no
way I was going to portray him he had
just been betrayed by absolutely
everybody including people in the
conservative media who had been you know
very supportive of him and had add him
on their shows and talk to them and then
suddenly it's like that week everybody
dropped him and I spent that week that
the post started out pretty pretty
emotionally heavy including the one
where I put posts simply posted a
quotation from my first book on when
Mary is feeling the swishing to suffer
with Jesus the suffering the teens and
one of what am i reader know there's
good what it was called mother and son
the post and one of my readers wrote to
me in an email saying was that for Milo
where you said that I'm like yeah and
she said thank you okay well and know it
because she then she proceeded to tell
me about her own son and and the
struggles that he had had and I'm like
this is this is a moment this is the
moment I must stay firm I know where my
Marian stuff comes from I learned a lot
about what it means to be a church you
in that week right because I suddenly
had people floods of letters coming to
me saying thank you so much for standing
up for him I'm so I admired so much what
he's done I've been encouraged by it I'm
feeling so sorry for him all these grand
Catholic grandmother's I had a whole you
know posse of Catholic grandmothers
writing to me saying that poor boy and
he's so he's so lucky to have you
and in the middle of that week I wrote
the famous poster I called the
Conservatives
[ __ ] Tim of a bad name which was one
but he had called them in one of his
pucks and that got shared by Rod Dreher
on American Conservative and that got
media's attention over the course of the
week I explained a few more things
including what I meant by saying he the
holy who land and how I think he's
modeling not only Jesus but Francis in
the kinds of jokes that he plays and
things like that to point out the
absurdity of the the culture so I
thought you know that was that was that
was my role that was my thing I had to
do this year was be there for him when
it all when it all went terrible and it
encourages me greatly to hear that it
helped you and I hope it helped others
just sort of step back from like wow
what just happened here someone who
actually is an abuse victim with
suddenly the bad guy yeah and and that
was very I was it was fascinating and
horrible at the same time to realize
that someone who refused to turn what
had happened to him real abuse into you
know his identity right he apologized
for it on the Wednesday said I'm sorry
you appreciate the things I said out of
context and certainly out of his context
and out of out of the context of
everything else he was doing could be
taken to mean something I didn't mean
I'm sorry now we're back to work right
he's never going to turn himself into a
victim either of the media or of his own
childhood because he thinks that that's
not the way you know very you know doing
what Jordan says right sort yourself out
recognize what you can do to to you know
make things better tell the truth and
you know get on with things you know
don't spend all your time you know
making yourself out to be the victim one
of the things I mean one of the things
about what you said the fact that people
only see it in one in one way see him
who was the victim of abuse as as still
as an oppressor mean it has to do
there's two things one is is the the
cognitive dissonance which which comes
from extremes the other has to do with
himself because the thing about about
chaos and about someone who
stands in a space in between and other
things is that I talked about this in my
video with with your is that they act as
a mirror and so when you look at them
all you can see are the things that
align with whatever you want that person
to be and you can't see that that that
let's say for example Milo that he is on
all sides and then no side at the same
time so you look at that you people will
look at them and what they say that he
is it ends up often being a mirror of
themselves like it ends up being what
they want him to be and so so so if he's
the white oppressor that's that's what
they'll see and they'll never see that
he they won't even realize like gay is
not part of it anymore
mm-hmm not part of it anymore he's only
that thing he said something no whatever
he said about about about about his
sexual adventures they'll only interpret
it in whatever frame do they already
have for him because he's he's breaking
out of all the frame so you have to
frame him you have to you have to be
able to give it put him in the category
and so I think that that I mean there's
there's been a lot of that happening and
it's been fascinating to watch the same
with Trump from is the same thing Trump
is not it's so funny because Trump is is
not really a right wing person at all I
mean and but but she is people are so
crazy that they look at him he's too
she's too all over the place and he's
actually not something and so they they
want they just push they know they make
like the fact that they would make him
into an anti-semite is the most insane
thing ever
I mean his daughter can write because I
mean it's crazy but it doesn't matter
it's like you know she doesn't she
doesn't fit what a president should be
we don't know how to deal with that so
let's we need you need to make them
something like let's make him whatever
we you think and it has to do with also
the pathology of extremes which is which
is this cognitive dissonance the
capacity to only see what's negative in
your opponent and only see what's
positive in yourself even though you
know and never never be able to see
whatever you're doing that's exactly the
same as your opponent and become mean we
saw that in
in the debates with jordan peterson was
really fascinating I mean the one they
did at the University who had two people
against Jordan one person saying you're
exaggerating
you know you're blowing this out of
proportion it's not a big deal you know
and then the other person saying you're
the devil you're Hitler you're the worst
you're the worst thing that ever
happened and you're you're being abusive
and horrible and they could maintain
those two discourses at the same time
and not realize that it's a absolute
cognitive dissonance and the people that
are watching it that are on that are you
know extreme left will will just eat it
up and they'll say and they can they can
accept both extremes that both like both
that contradiction they can just accept
it because of their their extreme
position so it's a it's a frightening
time to be in like I can I never can
never understand revolutions because we
lived in a democracy and that you know I
would read about the French Revolution I
would read about about what happened in
Russia and I'm like how can people how
could people normal people end up the
way that you would go out in the street
and guillotine women and like how's that
possible and now I'm starting to
understand how that works and I'm
starting to see how you can become so
pathological that you're incapable of
seeing that you're doing the same thing
that you're criticizing your opponent of
doing so it's it's a bit yet a bit of a
frightening moment right now
it's very frightening and you could say
I mean going back to the mirror people
could certainly argue that I'm seen in
my low myself which it's like that's
lovely if I see someone so lovely that
that I'm seeing him in Christian terms
because I'm Christian and I went to see
him in Christian terms yeah um but I'd
say you know the huge test and this has
always been for me what was so different
about Milo and was was really important
I talked about how I responded to the
original attacks on my three cheers for
white men poses the thing that I know I
needed to be was the happy warrior right
that at any moment if I turned into
someone who was throwing the same kind
of insults that were being thrown at me
I lose
right and and I actually did I've done
several posts in my blog not just about
about Milo about the issues but also the
how to's right how to be a happy warrior
how to answer the offense how to stay
calm when all of these kinds of attacks
are coming at you and that's why I you
know it's like of all the things I love
about Milo it's his example that no
matter what kind of insult gets thrown
at you you transform it and turn it and
give it back with with love in fact and
and the first one I did on in these
terms was called kung-fu Milo because I
was playing off the damage of the Kung
Fu Panda in the country Panda movies but
this fits with what Jordan does with all
of the superhero movies right now but
this is the Panda so in the comes with
panda movie the ideas the muskox the
evil musk ox is going around collecting
up all the Chi of the animal warriors
and he sort of colored all green with
envy right because he's envious of the
subsea energy and powers they haven't
he's capturing their golden energy and
turning them into little jade ornaments
that he can wear on his belt and so PO
the Kung Fu Panda has to figure out how
to fight him and I detail exactly if um
see movie all the see'em the ways that
he he finds his own people the Panda
people and he realizes they're not
really warriors and so they have to
become the kinds of warriors that they
can be with isn't in the first one this
is the third one okay yeah I didn't make
it to the third and first one there's
the sort of climax moment spoiler alert
is when PO ends up having to take
himself into the spirit realm to fight
the great Qi watch the great musk ox and
that you know the must of what the musk
ox has been trying to do all along is
it's like steel the other animal roars
life and Po has this moment where he's
supposed to be the Dragon Warrior which
is a lovely Peter Sounion image to write
when he realizes it to be the Dragon
Warrior it's not that he tries to hold
on to his Chi and protect himself but
that he he he he has this wonderful
moment when when he says you know you
want my Chi okay take it and he he's the
Dragon Warrior
point he sends out this great beam of
golden energy into the muskox which
explodes muskox right and it's it's
that's what I said Milo does right he
came all of the insults that everybody
throws at him you've seen it in the
posters that he's putting up for his
book right now hated man on the internet
he's like great I'll use that as my
banner yeah yep boo gross Sarah
Silverman cool fight that right but
anything that people throw at him he
does what Christians are supposed to do
he turns the other cheek and I he says
more he does even more than that he's
actually he's actually very it's very
it's it's you know that when you say
Kung Fu Panda I was thinking about the
first movie and and in the first movie
it's very similar structure where he you
know this during during his training
he's unable to master himself right by
the end he realizes that no it's it's
his very unreal teenis
that was going to be kind of higher than
let's say the masterfulness and so he
lets himself go to his you know to the
fact that he'd huge that he eats and
other stuff and you can kind of [ __ ] as
he's fighting at the end he's like he is
he is basically using his weaknesses as
an inverting them like using them
against his enemy in a really direct way
so I mean that's definitely that's
that's definitely been with Milo's been
doing it seems like that that's what is
that's that's I'm trying to understand
this thing like that's why when we
wonder stand Teddy the Frog and all that
it might understand these this character
that is that that is an inverted
character but then restores order that's
been like my focus on for a while now
that I've been focusing I've been
writing about st. Christopher and about
those types of liminal characters and I
and I like this is maybe why I think I
need to keep paying attention to Milo
somehow it has to do with King David we
I mentioned this to you in a private
discussion but I'm gonna I'm just going
to lay it out now that we we have this
image of King David as a king and and
often we ignore his actual story because
his story is very very disturbing
King David during his whole life until
he become
King she is an inverted character and so
he he is uh he comes a refugee and you
come to criminal and he he lived in a
cave and King Saul is hunting him
hunting and hunting him down and he
actually had some he does everything
like he acts when she acts insane in
clay and then he associates with the
enemies of Israel and even in Israel
people think that he is fighting for his
enemies basically and so but we know
that we know because we know the whole
story let's say you know we read it
before we know that she's secretly still
working for Israel so it's like she he's
acting completely inverted but she's the
secret King like he's she's secretly
trying to build the temple
that's the best way to say like he's
what he wants to do is establish the ark
build the temple but to do it she she
goes through this whole strange inverted
process and that's why also why he can
he can beat the giant because she has in
himself something similar to that giant
like he has he has a liminal quality
that makes him able to stand on the
underline and be able to fight the
opponent and so I'm been think I've been
really really thinking about that and so
it's interesting because like Milo says
he's Catholic says he's Christian but
then his behavior is so outrageous I
mean the behavior and the things that he
puts forth like I saw you know what I
thought recently when he did this thing
with like these women and he jabs at
strips and stuff is like oh my goodness
like what are you doing and so it's this
purpose like really ah yeah like he
really pushes the limit I need any you
bring I need just inverse everything and
so I know it's so so the idea is is he
secretly is like that I mean I think
that you tell me he is but I still need
I think for me it's still like the how
can I think it's that secret I think
it's obvious if you sit but you know
we're talking about you're talking about
the frames that we see true right like
it that you and I both see through
frames that a lot of people don't have
right that both both you and I are
fascinated by the way in which again as
we
talked about in the Jordan and Milo are
playing out these these very symbolic
roles and it's it to me it's like it's
so obvious I love your David comparison
with Milo because I think that fits
perfectly right David humiliates himself
dancing before the ark and and makes his
wife upset with him because he's willing
to expose himself in front of the
handmaidens and in this ridiculous way
and say 'no kabhi strippers okay I mean
that is obviously Milo saying leukopenia
western women can do this right the
women in the Islamic countries that are
forced to wear those niqab cannot and so
that's a celebration of the West and our
willingness to you know allow female
beauty to be something that my arguments
about chivalry right but the only reason
that I can walk down the street alone in
Chicago with you know a fair degree of
confidence that nothing is going to
happen to me is because most of the men
around me are going to respect that and
you know I think that that's that's an
aspect of our culture that is amazingly
easy to take for granted because it's
like air until it's not there anymore
and then you and then you're going to
suffocate so I see you know the the the
they were just dancing they you know
they took they took the bottom parts of
their Andy Cobbs off and kept the veils
on which was kind of funny um you know I
I to me if there's no question at all
but Milo is Christian but it's
interesting to me that it's it's still
difficult for you to be comfortable
I I say no no no no no no no I think I
think like I mean like if like if he is
less it's okay so this is going to be a
bit extreme I'm going to say something
that's a bit extreme but it's like
either so either he's a King David type
figure or he's a Nero right yes well I
was this Twitter handle the for the
right to mark that's why I say that and
so either he is so I don't know I I for
me I don't it does I don't I don't have
to judge anyways like I who am I to
judge it doesn't matter but I'm just
saying that those that's the question
I'm asking like which way it is
ambiguity going to going to going to
play and because if there's is there's a
you know you
you know there's a very strange
tradition about Nero by the way there's
a very strange tradition from in early
Christianity which is that Nero is going
to come back and come back as this like
ventral angel that will like restore
this weird kind of Justice so and then
some people think that like the like in
the in the end of India in Revelation
when it talks about the beast that dies
but then kind of comes back that that's
Nero actually right and then they you
know they're really great like the
Christians interpret our name I'll tell
you this when I changed my facebook
profile they have the picture of Milo
and me that we took on Sunday together I
suddenly had 666 followers nitrous so
you know you could be right I know I
don't think so because one of so one of
the things that Milo is is often accused
of doing is outing people for me either
being gay or being anything right he's
just that they're always there's there's
a persistent claim I mean including the
claim that got caught up with the
Twitter thing that he himself is
starting whatever bad things happen to
people is the doc scene or things like
that and and of course he hasn't it's
it's incredibly difficult to convince
people of this if they're seeing him
through the frame where he's Nero um but
one of the things that's impressed me
throughout the year that I've been in
correspondence with him is how
incredibly careful he is at who he names
under what circumstances you can see it
quite frankly in the way that he he
deals with his own staff right um how
many how many people actually know who
is working for him well only if they are
actually already public like pizza party
then will you know their names um and
and otherwise he's very protective of
his own of his own staff and he's he's
he's um he's been protective of me all
year it's been interesting what he will
and won't share on his Facebook feed
would that I give him and I'm like oh
come on and he says well no that's not
necessarily good for you um that he has
he was trained as a journalist and he
knows the kinds of things that are
actually already public and the kinds of
things that you simply don't say
right and and what I find interesting is
how you know CNN can well they're
getting trouble for that but you have
threatened to dock someone and Milo
would never do that right he's going to
make fun of CNN as much as you can but
it's it's the it's interesting what
people count as what belongs already in
the public sphere is Lena Dunham and Amy
Schumer are out there publicly saying
what they're saying so he's going to
talk about that and and that I've
followed him in my writing about the
people have been responding to me that
if someone publishes something on you
know out there I'll talk about it right
but I've had things that have happened
to me as it were behind the scenes that
I won't write about because they're
behind the scenes and they're not in on
the public record but and and Milo is
always very careful about knowing what
things are on the public record and what
aren't so I all can say that I'm very
happy that he has like a medievalist on
his team I think that that's great I
think it's a good it's a good sign for
sure so this is like so what's what
what's fascinating for me is our kind of
strange position both of us because you
know I met Jordan Peterson through
things that were completely unrelated to
his - no to his - what happened to him
that has to do with free speech and all
that and dealing with this question of
the marginal and the in-between spaces
you know it's the whole question it is
also has to do with these undefined
spaces that happen in this chaotic time
that we're in and so I at some point I
realized wait a minute like we're both
these kind of medieval type Christians
let's say or at least we see the world
much more - through a kind of many
medieval ontology I would say so I just
find it interesting that that we're both
kind of there in Christians - these two
characters because yeah like oh because
I mean for example I was curious to know
because never heard him speak about it
does viola know about Jordan Peterson
like has he ever heard of him as you
ever seen some of these videos oh yeah
look well I I was talking to him a
little bit on Sunday about yes he knows
he knows who he is and I mean my
Facebook friends are all saying oh you
know we've got to get
two of them to talk I think they've
talked maybe a little bit but not not
substantively yet okay all right and so
then so then maybe I could ask you that
so we met through your kind of interest
with Jordan Peterson you did you did the
his program and so maybe you can tell us
a bit about how you see that like how
you frame because I've seen that you've
been more intense pretty intensely now
into into Jordans material and so so I
mean I know because I'm coming from a
more I see in Jordan a lot a strange
resurgence of let's say a traditional
hierarchical ontology like something
that you would find in Dante let's say
but presented presented through a
Darwinian praying for me it's very
fascinating to kind of be part of this
and envy and so maybe I'd like to get
your take on you know what what is
drawing you to Jordan and how you how
you see that in relation to what you're
interested in terms of medieval history
and everything okay um I I was
interested what you were saying about we
as you and I as medievalist watching
these people and I'd like you to come
back to that but I'll answer this
question first so I was I was aware of
its like it's funny how you're sort of
my mildly aware of these things in the
middle of other things I listen to
Jordan's first the first video about
they'll see 16 while I was decorating my
Christmas tree which I'm sure was
symbolic in some ways um but I didn't
really that that was not an issue that I
was immediately interested in I was sort
of aware of him as oh yes another
professor who has been going through you
know the theum adventures this year I I
really became fully aware of him when
some of my friends posted the comment
that he made at the Manning Center
speech when first he was asked you know
was talking so beautifully about you
know how important it is to speak and
how its professors oh my goodness you've
got to be speaking because he was going
to otherwise and that was obviously
something I've been doing all winter
with the support of my own Dean and
president so I was like wow okay I like
this and and then in that same Q&A
someone asked him about Milo
and he came out with this thing about
Milos a trickster and I'm like oh my
goodness that's what I've been saying
I'd been saying holy fool but you know
trickster jokester exactly right that
that clearly we Jordan I were seeing
things from a very similar perspective
so I started watching his courses I read
his book
the maps of meaning I in in the course
of all this whole year not only did I
finish my book lose lots of weight
because Milo's fat shaming helps but I
also converted to Catholicism and at why
so this is this year the head in order
to Catholicism oh my goodness wow this
is big if I guess it's been a huge year
nothing's the same deal this time last
year I was like oh my goodness see if
I'd known what was coming it's been the
most exciting year in my life or one of
the most exciting years of my life has
had a few others similar but this is
this pretty much of the number of things
that have changed in less than 12 months
it's intense so I sent the winter going
through the Rite of Christian initiation
for adults and was received into the
church and at Easter and Jordan been
talking in his lectures about the self
authoring program acai well I very much
believe in writing yourself into
understanding because that's basically
what my blog had been since a bear
actually started out as my prayer to be
able to talk through some of the things
that I was learning through my sensing
which i think is also one of my
sympathies with Milo right I did do
something to really learn it right is
from physical and bodily but my knowing
that writing things out through the blog
had been so helpful I was I was really
drawn to Jordan's program of writing
yourself into solutions so after Easter
I did the novena
of the present authoring fault right and
then after Pentecost I did the president
present authoring virtues and I I was
I'm really impressed with the program as
a structure of writing one because it's
so contained right you can only write a
certain amount before the text box shut
you out and
help me I had to be really like crisp
and and yes crisp and concise and and
also that the structure of the exercise
is that you tell a story then you think
about what you would have done different
to make it better and then you think
about it in a general terms and Jordan
obviously talks about that as this is
you solving finding the answer in
yourself right finding the answer
through your own your own thinking about
it one of the things I found most
curious about all of it was one it was
easier for me to do the devices than the
virtues I'm clearly more comfortable
telling myself how bad I am then I am
giving myself credit for having virtues
in the first place um I also since I
found it hard to tell a story and I did
a blog post on that about this
experience of you know how much the few
times I was really able to tell a story
it was like blew my mind right it's
Jordans right that all of these emotions
and problems are just tangled up in the
stories that we haven't been able to
tell and I started I think I started the
Jordan has shared some of these in his
Twitter but that one of the most
powerful ones that I did was admitting
my own adultery so if you want to know
from back when I was in graduate school
and so with my second husband but it was
an adventurous sometime so you want to
know why so sympathetic to my looks like
maybe I've been there and I know what it
means to sin and I when I sent that went
to Jordan I'm like you I beg you to
tweet this for me I need everyone to
know tell the truth right and and and it
was sort of interesting thing because it
wasn't really when it happened back when
we were younger it wasn't like everybody
nobody knew because it was in the town
and everybody knew the town but then we
moved for when I took my job here in
Chicago and then nobody knew except for
a few colleagues and it it's very easy
to let that kind of thing just go away
right like and you end up you realize
you end up pretending to be more
virtuous than you actually know you were
or maybe you you know I spent too much
time not letting myself forgive myself
for have you made a mistake and I can do
better now right and and so all of that
was
just exactly as as mind-blowing as
Jordan promises it is that that if you
finally start telling the truth it's
amazing the things that will open up to
you that are you know you've been
shutting out because you haven't been
able to even admit to yourself that this
is something that you need to be able to
express yeah yeah so what is the
question you had about medievalists and
you said I want to go for that so so you
know I think to me this is this is just
so amusing right because as a
medievalist you know in academia um
particularly as a historian I'm in a
department that's largely modern modern
historians work on the period from about
the French Revolution to the present or
about the American Revolution to the
present most of them work on twenty
nineteenth and twentieth century or now
21st century history and for 20 years
I've been the one sitting on the side
going ah we knew that or you know
arguing the periodization problems like
mod modernity always used the Middle
Ages as its foil right the Middle Ages
are always wet cemaat modernity didn't
thought it wasn't yeah and and you know
the postmodern is interesting and this
is where I'd like to talk to Jordan more
intensively about this a lot of
post-modernism comes out of the fact
that those French philosophers whom he
rightly deplores um were trained as
medievalists yeah and and and and
particularly that that training and in
policy me um that he talks about they're
saying you know they see many layers of
meaning and text and multiple
interpretations well that is that's
medieval exegetical practice right now
the way medieval commentators read the
scriptures but of course what the post
modernists do is unmoor it completely
from blackness it's firstly there's
flattening right but but Roland Bart is
it Jordan doesn't mention him but he's a
great exponent of this idea of Poli see
me yeah I read you know Kalam about
mythologies is really was my
introduction to symbolism okay cuz I was
reading I was reading theoreticians and
I
red and when I read his mythology I
thought wait a minute he's doing
something more than the others
and so I I realized that he was doing it
as a critique like as a Marxist critique
right of these structures but I quickly
quickly realized no no this is
everywhere like it's not just in the
things you don't like it's also on the
things that you like and so it that was
like my that was one of my first like
awakening to this notion of symbolic
structures was reading cut on back which
you know then I never read again but as
well and so Bart was reading oddly daily
walks medieval exegesis right and and so
there's there's a there's a very clear
lineage my colleague Bruce holzinger has
done a book on this although I was a
priests and I are on politically
opposite sides we co-authored a volume
together we never learned this until
recently um that brief shows very
clearly that Bart was reading daily Bach
and got this idea of the scripture
having multiple senses and Bart's and
translates it into what all texts have
multiple senses but of course what he
doesn't carry over is the reason that
scripture has multiple senses and and
and the the reason that I mean Jordan is
being able to do the lectures that he's
doing on the psychological significance
of the Bible stories because the Bible
carries that kind of multi multi layered
understanding and so it's you know it's
it's interesting a facebook friend today
was asking a sort of Jordan understand
post-modernism like well what he needs
because is there something good in it
it's like what the good in
post-modernism is actually what it
carried over from the ancient the medial
an ancient tradition but the bad in it
is that of course it tried to make it
independent of the theological
mythological grounding that those
insights grew out of so that you and I
see what what Milo or Jordan is doing
within that that symbolic frame means
that we also see the postmodernist more
clearly because we understand why they
were able to make the kinds of arguments
they were I have I did a post back in
the winter on why Marxism is actually
Christian heresy I called it the Church
of the left and it's incredibly and it's
like the reason the reason that mark and
Roger Scruton has written well
about this - that's you know that there
most of the things that people are drawn
to have some truth in them and there is
a there is a truth in in Marxism about
you know concerns for for community and
concerns for well-being and so forth but
of course it's a heresy because as
Jordan likes to say you know these
ideologies are what does the word city
use they're imperfect right they put the
absolute at a lower level instead of
that's why that's why it to me the
problem with with a lot of the
postmodern and that type and and to say
that a modern world is that they they've
abandoned the idea of an ontological
heresy like they've abandoned the notion
that and so what they try to do is they
try to fully fit the absolute at a low
level of the world and so they try to
fully fit the absolute within the
political sphere let's say and that that
that is a crushing thing it can't work
that way it has to resolve itself as if
you move up the mountain and you enter
into the divine darkness you know it's
not it won't it'll never be fully let's
say fully realized in the in the in the
political sphere so I think like I
always think that data is really is
really like an upside down medievalist
and I use actually use a lot of his I
use a lot of data dolls ideas what I do
is I just I just tap them then I just
watch them flip back and then I'm like
okay I'm fine with that now as long as I
can just just tap that idea like you
know there's a light there's and there's
a lot of there's a lot of his ideas of
making those ideas in Jordan I tried to
convince Jordan of it hmm I know you
watch this I tried to convince them that
you that there's that you have to be
traveler that this idea of let's say
encountering monsters on the edge and
notion of faking the future and that you
know facing the unknown of the future
and then taming it I mean that's as
merely there indeed odd the difference
is that I think that's why why I like
Jordan more and I think that Jordan is
more balanced is that is that data only
wants to join with the monster like he
just wants them to sleep with the
monster like he wants to have this full
dislike union with you with
chaotic unknown whereas Jordan is saying
you know sometimes the unknown is this
potential like like you say like a
mother but sometimes it's also Tiamat
and it's not you have they're different
sometimes you have to kill the dragon
sometimes you tame the dragon sometimes
you have to to just leave the dragon
alone and just let it do its thing as
long as it's not bothering you it so you
have to you have to if there there's a
hierarchy it's always about here at key
like here's a hierarchy in the way you
address these things depending on on how
they they present themselves to you so I
mean so that's what I think like I a
minute we're going to come guys I'm
going to keep playing with this and I
know even in my discussion with Jordan
I'm going to push them a little bit on
these ideas about how to flip things to
flip things back on their feet and I
think that's what my that's why one of
the reason why I like Milo is I think
that one of the things that he's able to
do something upside down and to kind of
flip it back you know to just kind of
tip it and then he comes back into order
and so it's like that it's a good side
of the Joker let's say or the good side
of the of the like a yeah like an ill
idea figure if you like it right
he comes into an inverted world and then
he he's able to kind of tap it and they
come back into somewhat it starts
restarts the cycle let's say we starts
the order process so yeah anyways yeah
so there's somebody feedback about the
political and pushing the political that
that that was the other thing that I got
that I you asked me why I was
sympathetic to Jordan so on the one
level that he recognized Milo as a
trickster which I totally like you see
one other person that was saying that
like this is brilliant and and to that I
really appreciated his psychological
discipline because that's another thing
that I've been very very interested in
this you know training training and
virtue training myself as a fencer
training myself as a as a writer
training myself in in sort of to simply
self discipline so I was very drawn to
that the other was that that when he
talks and talks about that the sort of
layers of understanding it's like that
was exactly what I was trying to say in
the sitings piece that excited my
colleagues so much that Andrew Breitbart
which
who Milo likes to to quote like to say
politics was downstream from culture and
I said well culture is downstream from
religion yeah and right and we have
heard as and and and you know that I
didn't have space in that and I think
Jordan has also given me the language
over the last few months to articulate
what I think I mean by religion and I
think it's very close to what he means
by it it's the stories that we live and
you know I've been talking about
Christianity as a mythology for a while
now because I think it's it's it's not
just ritual or or creed right it's it's
these embodied stories that you you take
on and become and Milo does right he's
embodying Francis or Jesus or Kung Fu
Panda or Ava right but you're you you
live the story you don't just believe
something abstract about odds you have
to you know incarnate it and take it
into the world and and and and and
perform it and you know that Milo goes
off into campuses and gives these talks
in front of these kids that you know may
or may not want to listen to him Jordan
did the same thing right that was so
impressive
I've watched most of Jordan a lot of
Jordan videos unless you must too when
he that first free speech protest on
campus and when he couldn't talk inside
you just went out in the middle of the
courtyard and when the kids pulled off
his his mic he just says okay I'll you
know I'll talk right that that Jordan
clearly understands like Milo the
importance of being there embody right
your speech is one thing
academics are great at abstract speech
and we write it and stuff and and and
you know don't necessarily perform it
publicly that much both Jordan and mile
are willing to do that put themselves
physically at risk which they have been
my load travels with bodyguards um you
know whether Jordan does yet and and be
willing to be there in in in in their
bodies but that Jordan also understands
that what's happening to us what the
crisis that we're living through and
this is very much what I said in my
sightings article is religious it's a
crisis of what stories are we going to
live by what what truths are we going to
embody and when when I heard him say
that I was like that's
this this is the one other person I
found in academia who seems to
understand what I was trying to express
about what was going on in our culture
yeah I see it I see it like I I usually
use I like to use the word pattern
because the patterns embody themselves
in stories obviously but also in images
also in rituals and then also in in in
social structures and so the same the
same pattern let's say that's in the
beginning of Genesis and the creation of
Adam and Eve and heaven and earth and
these opposites that that then come
together you know that's the same
pattern the same reason it's the same
structure that makes our society be
based on marriage let's say right so the
story the story becomes the story if
there it's like there's an invisible
pattern behind the story then the ritual
then the you know then even in music and
all these things and it's all the same
it's all these same patterns so I kind
of like to see that I mean that's what
I've been trying to do is trying to
connect those things together you know
like the reason why you know like let's
say that that share a key of being that
we're talking about like that's why we
say God is in heaven and that's why we
say you know that that person is above
that other person like even though
they're not physically above that other
person there's a whole structure of a
pattern and the same structure that
makes us think that God or makes us say
they got it in heaven is the same reason
why we talk about a glass ceiling or or
like it's completely infiltrated into
our into our thinking this idea that
something which is more refined than us
would be above us mm-hmm it's so obvious
it's like one of the things that we use
all the time and language is the most
obvious thing ever but it's not it's an
image that we constantly use the image
of Cherokee is an image that that we
that is embodied in a language and in
stories and all these things and so so
yeah so I like that I kind of like to
see it as these as these patterns that
that's that that just structure the
world basically I think like I think I
mean for me
that's that's how I see myself as a
medievalist and I I mean my art and
everything that I'm doing is trying very
hard to live that in a world that is at
the margin of that that it's on the edge
of that and is watching those those
patterns kind of become fragile and and
then dissolve but I mean this hope like
there's this there's like there's a hope
that if the patterns are real they can't
dissolve it's just we dissolved if we
don't recognize right and it's an
anything live life out of the pattern is
is that that's what that's why for the
last we never know 20 years of my life
I've been trying to understand how the N
becomes the beginning like how did that
happen like how does something end and
then how does it turn into a new
beginning and so all these images of
monsters and a kind of GPS and all that
like that's what I that's why I've been
so focused on that is because I know
that it the secret is in that question
question of the of the buffer like what
happens in the buffer zone how does that
turn so I haven't completely figured it
out yet but I'm watering the passive so
as I watch it happen I'm it's helping me
to understand it right so yeah so I I
it's very it's very fascinating for me
what's happening in terms of I mean I
just like I said I finds it the
situation very interesting that you're
there with Milo this isn't kind of
Jordan and this is my theory like I told
you my theory about about Milo as being
kind of King David so this is my theory
about Jordan I think Jordan is kind of
like King Cyrus a lot of people don't
know the story of King Cyrus but King
Cyrus was a foreign King in the Old
Testament and when the when the Hebrews
were were out of their promised land
that they had been they've been you know
exiled out into into the Middle East
King Cyrus is the one who sent them back
you know go back home rebuild your
temple rebuild the walls of Jerusalem
you're like basically you have the right
to be what you are right until then the
idea of dispersing
people is to make them cease to exist
and dissolve into their like if you
disperse the people then you dissolve
them into the water like you just spread
them out and they stop to exist as a
unified thing right as Cyrus says no go
back you know and and and and build your
temple and so what's interesting about
Jordan is that he's very he's very
standoffish about saying whether he's
Christian or not he's not he's not part
of any church that's for sure he said he
said he said he was a Church of yellow
akeem akio right yes yes we all heard
that and so he kind of stands outside
Christianity somehow and then she's
saying he's basically telling Christian
to go back like go go back to your thing
like you're you're allowed to be
Christian you're allowed to to to to to
believe that too and and here and you're
allowed to rediscover how profound in
how how true it is but he and the reason
why he's able to do that is in a way
because she's standing outside yes if he
if he was at this moment in time let's
say if he was something like if he was
if he was I don't know like a
Presbyterian or if he was a Baptist or
Catholic or an Orthodox then people
would the people that are listening to
him would it would stop listening to him
I well I agree that so just as Milo is
standing on the border if I say noise
he's Catholic but gay
Jordan is interested in religion and
believes religion is necessary for us as
human being but is a scientist and you
have these two identities of the two the
two extremes are really opposites you
have someone who's who's on the inside
like King David let's say King David is
the secret king of the of the of the
Jews um but she's acting in a crazy kind
of foreign he's he's uniting with
foreigner geez he's acting in all these
inverted and liminal ways right have the
liminal King who's not at all part of
the inside who's on the outside but who
is sending people back towards the
inside ain't really nice I was kind of
interesting what's fascinating is is
that I that I realized that
there are actually only two characters
in the Old Testaments that are called
like messiahs and those are the two King
David and I decided it was like these
it's as if Christ what Christ does it
takes those two extremes and unites them
in one person yes
he takes like the you know and then we
look at Christ's story you'll see that
he actually does that he takes it yeah
and Christianity is kind of that story
of the two extremes of how the inside
and the outside can can come together
somehow right and so and so yeah it's
interesting it's interesting it's well
it for sure is hopeful that maybe these
two extremes are there and are helping
to re-establish something that is
holding like that's something that is
that makes sense hopefully that's true I
hope so I hope so
it's also one of the things I wanted to
talk to you about is I know that you're
that you're going to publish a book very
soon on on on Mary and symbolism so
maybe you can tell us a little bit about
that I'd love to
so the book is called Mary and the art
of Prayer the hours of the Virgin in
medieval Christian life and thought and
its focus is this cycle of prayers that
most people know now is the little
office of the Virgin or the hours of the
Virgin because their prayers that are
said throughout the liturgical day in
honor of Mary the most famous part of
that hours most people know although
they don't necessarily realize that they
know it it's the Hail Mary of a Maria
which was in fact technically the the
inventory for this office it was the
opening chant was used with the opening
psalm and in the Middle Ages because it
the ideal was everybody is involved in
this service to Mary everybody's
involved in praising Mary if they didn't
know the full hours all of the Psalms
and all of the prayers and all of the
other chance they could it could serve
Mary appropriately simply by saying sets
of Ave Marias or Hail Marys and and
obviously that practice turns into
things like the Rosary and even you know
even today that's still very popular
practice but what's here
about the hours of the Virgin is
although there's stories about it being
sort of mandated for everyone to say I
was in fact never the case in the Middle
Ages that it started as a additional
practice that monks and nuns were doing
in the 11th and 12th centuries and
laypeople over the 12th and 13th
centuries because they modeled their
prayer life on that of the monasteries
started asking to learn the hours of the
Virgin as the way in which they could
also to serve in the regular prayer of
the church and it was always voluntary
practice by the end of the Middle Ages
there's a whole new kind of book
invented so that people can say these
hours they're what we call books of
hours so and and most people if they've
seen a medieval manuscript they've seen
a book of hours because those are
beautiful pictures and they're and
things and and so my book is my book is
about the the way in which this practice
developed the kinds of things that we
know from the stories that people told
about their experience of saying
particularly the Ave Maria and then
getting deep into the actual symbolism
of what the office was about mm-hmm and
so what was I mean what drew you to that
subject right now what was the thing
that made you want to write about this
in particular well so I've always been
interested in prayer and I've my whole
career has also been working on devotion
to Mary I have a big beef with the
feminists who I think have badly
distorted the importance of Mary in the
Christian tradition in the Western
tradition and I love to talk about that
I got to this particular project through
the first book that I wrote which was on
commentaries on the song of songs in
praise of Mary and Christ and if you
know the song of songs it's the dialogue
between the bride and the bridegroom and
what's very interesting about the ways
that book was used in the Middle Ages in
the liturgy it's primarily used for the
offices of the feasts of Mary that the
chants particularly is the Feast of the
Assumption
taken from the song of songs and in the
12th century there were commentators who
were curious about this why in the
liturgy do we say this text when as they
said in one of the commentaries it
doesn't seem to have anything to do with
her in the 12th century there a number
of monastic commentators that use this
that use the fact of the Song of Songs
being used in the Marian liturgy to make
the Song of Songs into basically the
story of Mary's relationship with Christ
so back when I was talking about the the
posts that I shared about Milo and in
February on the mother mother and son
that's taken from one of these 12th
century commentaries that transforms the
Song of Songs into the conversation that
Mary and Jesus Mary and Christ have as I
mean lovers because Mary is both the
most perfect soul in relationship to God
and of course the mother of the
Incarnate son and that love that they
have is beautifully expressed through
the song of songs so in the in the
present book it's like I'm taking that
out a further frame and showing not just
the way in which one book of the Bible
the song of songs used in a Marian
context but in fact the way in which all
of the Scriptures were read through a
Marian frame and in the hours of the
Virgin this is made but sort of
performative by way of the framing of
the Psalms the hours people are familiar
with the hours it's the practice of
saying in monastic traditions the
practice of saying the Psalter once a
week right and in the Marian office
there's a flexion of Psalms that are
used some of them taken from the fact
that they're used for her feasts and
others as I explained in my book for a
variety of reasons but all of them are
said in the Marian office framed by
champs that basically showed the
understanding that the medieval
Christians had of her as the frame for
God right right this is that she that
the antiphon frames the Psalms the
antifoam will be about her blessed are
you among women
let us sing the sweet songs the
before the couch of the Virgin and then
the psalm will be about her son Christ
and of course that it involves reading
the Psalms as in fact about the Lord I
don't I who with whom Jesus is
identified when when early Christians
say Jesus is Lord they mean he's God and
they mean therefore he's Yahweh they
mean he's he's that the one whose name
cannot be pronounced so you say Lord
instead of Yahweh and and so Mary
framing the Lord in the Psalms is Mary
framing God and right in the way in
which he became incarnate through her so
my my book is about sort of it's also
got this experimental level in its
methodology that I set up each of the
different chapters by inviting you as
reader to imagine yourself same
particular elements of the office so
firstly in veget or E Ave with its psalm
than an anti phone the first anta phone
blessed are you among women with it
Psalm Psalm 8 and then the lessons that
are largely taken from ecclesiasticus so
they're all about Mary as wisdom and
then the prayers and and the idea is you
as reader get to be to kind of step
inside this practice just as medieval
Christians used that practice and we
have pictures of them doing this in
their in their books of ours to step
inside into the sacred space with Mary
by way of their service to her and
praising her through through this office
yeah what's interesting about what
you're saying is that in your own
methodology you're reproducing you're
reproducing this the feminine symbolism
in this invitation because that's a
strong part of of the feminine symbolism
is this idea of inviting like you said
inviting the the believer to step in and
to participate and so like that's that
that's exactly that frame you know if
the invitation is the frame that leads
you in let's say to the service oh I
don't know if you did on a purpose but
well now like I think I did but now you
just did to me what I used keep doing to
Milo
okay it's like did you realize that this
is what you were doing is you know oh my
gosh your
right that yes that make them make
better sense yeah but I think you know
one of the things that I'm realizing and
I think that it's actually it's actually
obvious is is one of the problem of the
age right now one of the problems of the
ages is is a proper engagement and a
proper understanding of the feminine
it's like the fight the fight that's
happening is is over what is the
feminine and and one of the problems
about that is that the feminine is how
can I say this the feminine is a
question like the feminine is the is
that invitation
it's that question and so it's it's
actually very difficult to answer the
what like if you say what is the
feminine it's really hard it's hard to
do it to do it precisely because it's
the feminine asking the what like it's
the feminine
asking for this a identity to manifest
itself it's the feminine lives that's
like that it's the feminine that is that
let's say is that opening for for
something to happen and so it's like
it's very it's very difficult I've been
I've been wrestling with this myself
when I when I talk about feminine
symbolism it's like I've been really
wrestling with how much do you you say
how much do you imply like how much do
you suggest it's like sometimes if you
there's something that if you say to
explicitly you make them false let's say
I don't know how yes well yes it's
sometimes I mean that you and I both
appreciate the deep power of metaphor
and but I think the things the things
that you say you articulate to to
metonymically or descriptively to use
north reprise language since we're
thinking about Jordans reading to um
they kind of lose life right and that
that is a problem that the truths that
are embedded in the stories it's like
the more you unpack the stories there's
this moment of understanding but then it
needs to still be in the story it needs
to still be something you can live or
act through for it to continue to be
alive otherwise it turns into this dead
thing that you you
right long academic books about with
lots of footnotes but it doesn't
activate anybody's understanding anymore
it's this so I you're saying about that
the problem of the feminine this is this
is where my beef with the feminists came
in that I actually started working on
devotion to Mary in college basically
and that's thirty years ago so the I was
very frustrated I read a lot of feminist
theology back in the 80s and a lot of
Mary daily and rosemary Royer and marina
Warner's book on Marian all of them had
were just angry at the way in which they
they thought Mary had been designed or
imagined in Christianity and the Mary
daily had was with well it's all of them
but you know the primary way of thinking
about Mary's Abeid they came up with was
that she was basically raped by God
which goes against the medieval
tradition which is that as we're not
asked also the scripture because there's
this there's this moat like you yeah and
like is that even in the tradition they
people really go into that moment when
the when Gabriel announces to Mary right
that she received like it's really
important in the tradition and even in
the text really I mean implies that she
does she accepted like that she accepted
that this was going to happen to her
well you remember in my three cheers for
white men consent was one that that the
the tradition of Christian marriage
being constituted by consent goodness is
a huge change it's a huge change in yeah
and and in in in in the Western
tradition that the argument that the
Canon lawyers make is developed in the
12th century and it's it's deeply
embedded in arguments about what happens
to Mary at the moment of the
Annunciation and Bernard if Bernard of
Clairvaux has a wonderful passage in one
of his homilies where he has the whole
world lies prostrate at your feet
waiting for your consent right for Mary
to say yes and then you know God did not
want to take flesh from her unless she
was willing and so you know even
embedded in that Mary tradition there's
the sense that God is not God could have
raised her
but that's not what that's not how God
wanted to work salvation and so her
consent was was very important so on the
one hand that you know daily and company
of the feminists were you know trying to
make this into the God the Father rape
story um the other is an artifact of the
19th century focus on the search for the
historical Jesus right and and you know
now we have this culture of sort of what
would Jesus do and it feeds into my
reading of my lo is Jesus to that people
have this this image of Jesus now is
he's well he's either I did a blog post
on this called signed with the cross
where I'm talking about Jordans reading
of the hero mythology - that Jesus is
either the sort of vagabond socialist
which is kind of interesting late 19th
century image or he's just sort of
saccharine and you know too sweet for
good you know kids book
you know he loves little children and
lambs and stuff like that like you know
seriously this is a guy who went into
the temple with a whip and drove out the
money changers and made everybody so mad
at him that they killed him so there's a
what we've done with that image right
with it that there are theologians in
the mid 19th century they're very
interested in recovering what they think
is the historical Jesus and of course
for them the historical Jesus probably
wasn't God um probably could have been a
little crazy was probably you know extra
non does this in his life of Jesus which
is a very important watershed and this
kind of thinking modern Christians tend
to have nothing of the mythological
layer of who Jesus who medieval
Christians say Jesus was which was the
Lord the monster slayer the lord of the
psalms who kill you know captain draws
leviathan out with a hook and you know
tramples on behemoth right all the all
of the Marduk imagery that Jordan was
talking about is embedded in the psalms
as well that he's the one who sits in
his throne sits upon the waters he he
came the flood he is the one who you
know overcomes the forces of evil and
and and that image of Jesus as
Lord is very much alive throughout the
Middle Ages inducted into into the early
modern period and imagining Jesus not
just as this man who had a historical
existence which again I'm thinking about
the lectures that you and and Jordan
both gave on the logos but it matters
that he had a historical presence right
it matters that he becomes incarnate in
a particular historical moment but it
also matters that he was the
transcendent Lord and and and you know
the great hero who treated and
transcends all of the hierarchies um
that level in orthodoxy instilled his
main image of Christ is right Christ as
this judge that expands above in the
dome I mean he canon but you can't avoid
it
but it's been lost in the West right
because the the the exegetical tradition
the commentary tradition of Western
theologians has been much more focused
on this this historical person and even
Pope Benedict whom I adore in many ways
for his his theology in his Jesus of
Nazareth series talks about needing to
recover the older exegetical tradition
but doesn't do it which I found just
fascinating right it's like where is all
the medieval tradition where you're
talking about you know the great mystery
of the Incarnation is that God so
humbled himself right God entered into
his own creation through Mary and I'd
like to talk about that as an artistic
problem as well but this sort of at the
level of the mystery of the divinity
incarnate is something that I think most
modern Christians have a lot of
difficulty with and certainly in the
church that I converted I've been
attending an Episcopal Church for 14
years and you know the sermons that you
hear in the Anglican Church of the
Episcopal Church has very little actual
doctrine in them and and very little
wrestling with this problem of how can
you say God was in creation yeah and so
if you as all you should be talking
about time and and and and you think
about that's why that's why modern
feminists don't get married right
because just as Jesus is reduced to this
probably crazy guy fraud Fuller what how
to CS Lewis put it either he's a
well I don't remember what it is but
either you believe in Murray's crazy
right yeah um that Mary similar in Sept
diminished by that right so she all she
can be under those circumstances is is a
sort of good model woman right and and
of course though if that's what you grew
up with in the mid 20th century then
you're not going to get the cosmic marry
that the medieval Christians are
describing greater than that Ben's right
the we know it's like she who contained
in her womb he whom the heavens could
not contain exactly uh and and and that
that medieval imagery you know it it's
the most ancient and I in my book I talk
about how that that imagery probably
goes back to the ancient temple it's
it's not just that and this I'm relying
on Margaret Barker's work in her temple
theology that it's not just that the
Christians claim that Jesus was lord
they claim that Jesus was Lord because
they're expecting the fulfillment of the
scriptures and what they expect to be
fulfilled is the return of the Lord to
his temple right and so but that I think
that that's the main thing to understand
is that just as the Old Testament has
has structures and has images which
point to what Christ is all through the
Old Testaments they're they're all these
stories and images that point to what
what Mary is is right idea everything
that it is the underlying support the
frame that the Ark of the Covenant you
know there's Noah's Ark all these things
that acts as the as the vessel for the
logos I mean they're everywhere in the
Old Testament you know so it's
interesting what you're saying is
interesting that you yeah and I think I
agree that a lot of amount of Christians
would never even think to read the Bible
like that no because the moderate the
modern commentary practice cannot
support that right the Old Testament is
one thing the New Testament is another
Judaism is one thing Christianity is
another these two things don't you know
and and of course medieval Christians
and this is I think this is important
culturally and politically and socially
for us in the 21st century post
Holocaust and whatever else that means
to understand why Christianity and
Judaism have the history
relationship that they do because it's a
real argument over how to interpret the
the you know the claim of who's
fulfilled the prophecies and you know
it's it's not it's not that odd in the
sense that you know even modern would
say more mystical modern Judaism they
they they have this whole feminine
aspect in their in their vision of like
in their mystic vision and let's say
everything that they would say is the
feminine aspects in their mystic vision
is everything that we would point to
Mary and so it's really interesting like
all the same stories that they would
interpret as being as being let's say an
image of what Mary will be they'll show
that they'll use it at the same in the
same way but within maybe in a more
abstract way to talk about like this
kind of feminine container for the
divine so so it just yeah it's very
fascinating and and this is that exactly
and the the kinds of it and Mary Mary
the primary image of Mary in the
medieval West and I they're getting a
lot of this from the Orthodox tradition
because they get it through the well one
through the liturgies of Mary which come
from the East particularly in the the
seventh and eighth centuries with the
Greek in Syrian Pope's in Rome so
there's there's a period in Rome when
much of the papal liturgy is in Greek
and the Marian feasts seem to come they
come into the West at that point and as
I read it they come with the scriptural
associations that they had in the East
and we definitely know that for example
andrew of crete is very closely
associated with some of the popes in the
day and he is the author as i'm sure you
know of some of the most important and
beautiful marian homilies and those
homilies are just stuffed full of all of
these places that andrew finds mentions
of mary in the old testament and so it's
it's it's the great mystery of God's
presence in his creation over and over
and over again and the England and the
core place where she becomes the Lord
becomes present is in the temple and so
Mary is the temple she's prepared as the
temple in which the Holy of Holies is
through which that the logos comes into
the world and and what's lovely for the
practice of the office the Marion office
is that in the in chronicles it's
described how it's the singers who sing
the Psalms on the temple steps and the
the temple skills with the light and the
incense and such in the presence
manifested health that's why that that's
the way medieval Western Christians
describe the importance of singing the
films in honor of Mary it's there like
you're singing the presence you're
seeing you you're singing before the
Lord you before the throne of the Lord
with the Angels but it's also the
service that that is important is
critical to the temple because it's
through that song that and you can say
you know experientially this works
because people singing off and do
experience that sense of the Lord
becoming present for them right and
everything's experiential and symbolic
at the same time and I mean it has to do
with this idea of the end of the
invitation and I and that's part of you
can kind of see this this whole image
you know in Revelations of the church
you know chanting and singing come Lord
yet and and you can realize that that's
what it is that's that's the the
feminine aspect you know that is
inviting that is asking for the the
lover to come like you see in the song
of songs like right this call and this
this invitation know there's a there's
an interesting aspect let's say in
Orthodox in the Orthodox liturgy which
is you cannot have a you cannot have
communion without someone in the the
nave saying Amen like it is impossible
is it there is no Sacrament there is no
there is no church service without
someone in the nave saying Amen and that
a man is that is it let it be like it's
that right that yes that's the same yes
that Mary gave to to the Archangels like
like yes here is here comes the light
here comes this this strong you know
powerful thing and and it's not going to
happen unless I say yes unless I unless
I let it happen you know it's also this
yeah so there's really a lot of debate I
think it's just a key it's the
she thinks understand right but I love
that and so this is what we talk about
one of the things I wanted to talk about
that image that Jordan always loves to
show in his lectures of Mary as the
container for God right and that it's
it's that that's an image that it's a
15th century image that's in some ways a
to Clooney in Paris and when Jordan
shows that he's usually just showing the
open statue right but it has both a
closed and an openings like you're
talking about the invitation and the
opening right these these these little
opening virgins sometimes they're called
shrine Madonna's um there we have about
40 of them extant from from the later
Middle Ages that you know they're sort
of performative as a piece of art as
well that that close they show Mary
holding the child and the Clooney image
he's standing on her knee and she's
holding the little ball which could be
an Apple could be a globe could be a
symbol of his power could be a sense of
like this is the globe that he's going
to enter into the world right they're
going to enter in a way that she's the
globe really but that she's and then
then she opens and you know the mr.
great mystery is God is fully in
incarnate through her and um there's a
phrase that she's called the the Turk
lynnium of the Trinity in one of adam of
st. Victor's sequences so she's she's
somehow the resting place of the Godhead
which for some later medieval
theologians was heretical they saying no
she's just the mother of the second
person but well how are you going to be
talking about the Trinity because
there's also um people like Hildegard of
Bingen has wonderful imagery in her
visions that mary is basically the one
that makes God visible to the world not
just do the Incarnation the son becomes
physical and invisible but because the
son becomes incarnate and visible to the
world that makes God no saline I think
in that image that image in Jordan shows
at least I mean I have a lot of sympathy
for it but for sure for sure from an
orthodox perspective it's it's heretic
it's a he has a proper medical in
several ways especially since there's a
really strong emphasis right now in
kind of rediscovery of Orthodox
iconography that sense that this
tradition of showing God the Father as a
as a person in problematic and so we
don't you don't do that we would say for
example that that that that Mary made
the Trinity incarnate in Christ right
right and so what you see is always
Christ and in Christ you see the Trinity
so you don't actually have to like
visually show the Trinity right I think
I would I think that the image itself
and I'm going to and I'm going to put up
the one of the I just I'm going to put
up that earlier image that you that you
mentioned as well like an earlier
medieval image that shows pricing glory
inside her yes so that one that one is
lovely it's in Baltimore it's at the
altars and I think that one's probably
more orthodox in other ways
yeah because it shows it shows Mary Holt
well it or not Orthodox in a way because
closed it shows her holding Christ in
majesty but they're not and not is the
baby great and then open it shows in her
body the events of the passion and the
resurrection which is therefore much
more the Incarnation yeah the embodied
Incarnation audience but but what I love
is in in her head is still Christ in
majesty so it's it's an understanding
that there's a whole tradition that also
comes into my book of Mary in
contemplation sees sees God even well I
mean she doesn't have the beatific
vision in her life but but she sees God
face to face and understand sinfully in
her mind and I think that ivory is
trying to show that sense of her
contemplation of understanding the
divinity even as she participates
through the Incarnation and her in her
in her body and the Song of Songs
commentaries are that I worked on in my
first book or full of that kind of
understanding of she's her flesh is
Christ's flesh but their relationship is
that it shows the divinity as well as
his humanity right and in doing and
that's where we say that she's she's our
hope because she's the promise of what
we can be like she's the promise of what
she's that she's the you know in a way
she's like a
as the church as the receptacle of God
as the place where God can manifest in
transform us like she is she is the one
we need to to see as our hope like so
and in yours about tradition we I mean
we believe that she was the first to be
deified we that she was the first right
to be fully and completely United in the
manner to which that's possible for a
creature to be united with with with her
creator and so don't they go as far as
to say that she is you know the
distinction is that she remains a
creature but that but that she's fully
participates in in God to the extent
that it's possible so so so she is like
this she is the one who invites us as
well to do to become that she's the
first you know you know she's that she's
she's notice about this this is this is
this imagery is this is what I love
about the medieval tradition it really
is Orthodox yeah just that most modern
Christians don't know it so they don't
they don't recognize that the traditions
are much closer but in the commentaries
that I'm working on particularly from
the 13th century of all of her names in
Scripture in all the places that they
find her in Scripture that they get to
the place where saying she is most like
God right she's she's day acing this day
SEMA at which sometimes they fall into
saying she's a goddess but what they
mean is she's the perfect reflection of
God should they like the the passage
from wisdom where she is the mirror of
His Majesty and the unseen of the odds
it should be able to quote that
perfectly but I can't
the unspotted mirror of his majesty
right and so she is the most perfect
reflection of the image and likeness in
which she was made and and that that
reflection of the image and likeness is
always so very very important that she
becomes she's wisdom because she most
perfectly reflects with them she's
godlike because she most perfectly
reflects God so she is the human soul as
it was made in it in its perfection
which means it has nothing to do with
whether she's feminine it's much more
important that she's the creature of the
creator and and therefore his most
perfect work mmm she is feminine in the
sense of that of that idea of
the water like of this idea of the water
is that is the potential and so it can
be chaos but it can also be the thing
that like you said that is the pool on
which you know the cereal and the you
know the the thing that has no
concreteness can be reflected and so the
the the highest the highest instance of
that would be the one that received all
of the all of the different boomers
became I mean became God as we okay so
world I mean III did very fascinating I
hope people I hope people work your book
when is it coming out well so I'm
working on the index right now and
hopefully if that all goes to schedule
our book will be out in November what is
it what it is my toll again Mary and the
art of prayer will be definitely looking
out for that thank you yeah and I know
is there something I I think we could
wrap it up is there something that you
wanted to talk about something about
there's something in your book that you
feel it's important for people to hear
well I think we've given people a lot to
think about so I hope you and I get to
do more videos all right yeah we'll
definitely plan on that a date one other
thing I want to do together and I hope
that we can get the chances to help
people understand kind of the symbolic
way of looking at the world yes and the
way that that the people in the in early
Christianity were able to unite you know
the the concrete world with the the
spiritual realities and and how they
flowed out of each other like how the
material world flows out of meaning and
so that's how the medieval understood
the world and I think that that's yes
one of the things that Jordan is
bringing back it's strangely from the
bottom up you know it's as if the
medievals would have understood it
really as you know like the disease
spiritual essences that that come down
and find bodies in the world whereas
cheese strangely able to do it and kind
of come from below and say or here's the
world this is what it looks like you
know I'm a scientist and and and and and
then rebuild this Cherokee from the
bottom
it's something that's very fascinating
to watch happen mm-hmm I agree yeah hmm
all right so I hope yeah so let's let's
do this again for sure excellent thank
you thanks a lot